[Musique]
distillerie ici c'est chez moi la
compagnie plus précisément entre lioret
et pont-audemer à saint simon ici on est
loin de toute technologie mais il ya
quand même de la place pour ma passion
avant de vous en parler je me présente
je m'appelle question 11 ans je suis en
sixième un patient ce n'est pas le poney
mais l'informatique
alors ça c'est mon ordinateur alors un
ordinateur ces composés d'un moniteur
avec un écran à l'arrière tous les
circuits qui c'est qui servent à faire
marcher à faire apparaître les
caractères alors ici les caractères sont
en vert c'est un écran monochrome
en dessous il ya les boutons pour régler
la luminosité le contraste et puis la
verticale alors ça comporte aussi un
clavier avec des touches tous les
touches de l'alphabet et les fonctions
propres à l'ordinateur hauteur mais que
heskey potable etc
et alors ici il ya un lecteur de
disquettes
alors c'est au lecteur de disquettes cd
disque est un rouge ces accords et sa
bande des logiciels et les logiciels
c'est toute une suite de programmes pour
pouvoir mettre un jeu ou un logiciel en
marche
alors là je hais les chats de mon
ordinateur je mets un disque est de 12
et je j'appelle le jeu qui s'appelle
commando
qu'est ce que tu peux faire exactement
avec un ordinateur avec un ordinateur on
peut s'amuser se distraire que s'il
faire les programmes plus complexes les
programmes qui font un calendrier des
choses comme ça l'est encore plus elle
n'aime pas faire beaucoup beaucoup de
choses et penses-tu qu'un jour l'homme
pourrait être dépassé par cette machine
non non non c'est un changement je pense
pourquoi parce que faut vraiment qu'on
lui donne des ordres sinon c'est
vraiment une machine nul de rien du tout
est ce que par hasard la pratique de
l'ordinateur te plaît à un tel point que
tu voudrais en faire un métier
voilà je sais pas mais je crois pas donc
je crois pas que je voudrais en faire un
métier d'agent ce pas c'est pourquoi que
non je reprendrai c'est bien pour les
jeux mais peut encore mieux faire mais
qui dans le samu sport et puis ça ne
parle pas si intéressant que ça de faire
que des programmes des programmes à part
les jeux sur l'ordinateur est ce que tu
sais faire des programmes où je serai
offrir alors là je vais faire un
programme un programme au sein très
simple en basic
c'est un langage pour les débutants
alors l'ordinateur va me demander mon
nom et va répondre c'est bien la
variable alphanumérique que je révise tu
vas tu me tues et reconnu
alors ça y est mon programme est
terminée alors là input c'est
l'information et print c'est la réponse
de l'ordinateur alors je lance mon
programme
l'ordinateur me demande quel est ton le
jeu répond bien à l ordinateur me
réponds tu t'appelles gaye passion john
c'est super super super salut fr3
[Musique]